verstehe ich nicht das land schon
draußen auf dem boden das ist voller
bakterien ließen jetzt auch leer
weißt du was ich war jetzt ein
referendum das so groß ist wie diese
hier
um es ganz genau zu nehmen ist mein xxl
raffaello sogar größer als die
honigmelone und somit heiße ich euch
herzlich willkommen zu meinem neuen xxl
video und jetzt zeige ich euch wie ihr
das xxl raffaello ganz einfach zu hause
nachmachen können wir starten
zuallererst mit der creme dafür
benötigen wir weiße kuvertüre
schlagsahne und mascarpone
die sahne wird in unserem topf ein mal
aufgekocht und sobald sie dann hoch
steigt gießen wir sie über die klein
gehackte weiße kuvertüre
ganze decken wir dann für etwa fünf
minuten ab damit die weiße kuvertüre
schon mal in der heißen sonne schmelzen
kann anschließend verrühren wird das zu
einer homogenen masse
damit erhalten wir unsere garage die
jetzt etwas gelblich aussieht das ändern
wir aber später zuallererst muss sie
vollständig abkühlen
für den kern des raphaels benötigen wir
blockierte mandeln und weißem zucker da
ist selbstverständlich keine so große
mandel auf der welt gibt müssen wir die
mandeln jetzt zuallererst an gerüsten
und dann mit hilfe des zuckers zu einem
großen kern verarbeiten
damit wir eine schöne runde kugel
erhalten müssen wir die gerösteten
mandeln jetzt grob hacken
den zucker erhitze ich in derselben
fahne auf mittlerer stufe bisher anfängt
zu schmelzen
jetzt haben wir den perfekten kleber für
unsere mandeln
die gebe ich jetzt auch noch mit dazu
und verrührt das gut miteinander
die mandeln werden dann in den händen zu
einer kugel geformt aber bitte bitte
seid vorsichtig bei diesem schritt ich
habe mehr handschuhe angezogen und meine
hände mit den handschuhen in kaltes
wasser gelegt damit ich sie überhaupt an
fassen konnte lasst euch zu nun einfach
helfen und schneidet die kugel
anschließend in der hälfte einmal durch
nach etwa eineinhalb stunden im
kühlschrank ist die weiße ganache auch
abgekühlt dass es ganz wichtig dass die
komplett kalt ist sonst lässt sie sich
nicht aufschlagen
die fülle ich dann in meine rührschüssel
um damit ich sie in meiner
küchenmaschine mit dem schneebesen
aufschlagen kann
ihr könnt selbstverständlich auch euer
handrührgerät dafür benutzen
sobald ihr dann merkt dass die creme
ziemlich hell geworden ist geht sie die
mascarpone mit dazu achtet bitte darauf
dass er das nicht zu sehr schlag
ansonsten bekam risse licht das tut dem
geschmack zwar keinen abbruch aber das
sieht nicht mehr so schön aus
nachdem die mascarpone kurz ein gerät
wurde ist die leckere creme auch schon
fertig und wir können starten unser
raffaello aufzubauen
für den schritt benötigen wir außerdem
noch geschmolzene kuvertüre und waffel
blätter die bekommt die in jedem
größeren supermarkt
ihr habt jetzt zwei möglichkeiten
entweder ihr nehmt euch eine beliebige
schüssel die hat wirklich jeder zu hause
und kleidet sie mit alufolie 1
dieser schritt ist auch ganz wichtig
damit ihr die halbkugeln später auch
wieder aus der form bekommt ich habe von
meinem toffifee video noch die silikon
halb vom da deswegen verwende ich die
auch in diesem video das xxl toffifee
video verlinkt ich euch
selbstverständlich am ende dieses videos
unsere waffen blätter tunken wir in
etwas milch für eine sekunde und lassen
sie dann etwa eineinhalb minuten stehen
damit sie schön weich werden und sich
unsere halbkugel vom anpassen
dann kann es auch schon losgehen wir
streichen etwas von unserer weißen
kuvertüre in die form und geben dort die
waffe drauf
und geizt auch nicht mit der ouvertüre
denn die mehr verwendet desto stabiler
wird eure kugel später
sobald dieser schritt getan ist geben
wir unsere creme hinein
nun kommt unserem mandelkern ins spiel
wir hatten den er anfangs in der hälfte
durchgeschnitten und jetzt geben wir
eine hälfte mit der schnitt seite nach
oben in die mitte ganz wichtig dass die
halbkugel für mindestens 4 stunden ins
gefrierfach wandert damit sie auch schön
fest werden kann
selbstverständlich benötigt ihr zwei
dieser halbkugeln die habe ich in der
zwischenzeit auch schon hergestellt und
entfernen sie jetzt aus der form
die abstehenden waffeln schneidet ihr
dann ganz einfach mit eurer küchen
schere ab damit die kugeln auch besser
aufeinander passen
als kleber dient jetzt unsere
geschmolzene weiße kuvertüre die gebe
ich auf den rand der waffeln und gäbe
dann die zweite halbzeit mit ich darauf
sobald die zwei halbkugeln dann mittig
aufeinander liegen könnt ihr mit eurer
winkel palette noch einmal alles schön
glatt streichen am rand
da unser raffaello tiefgefroren ist ist
die kugel kalt und die warme kuvertüre
wird dementsprechend schnell fest also
arbeitet hier bitte schnell gibt etwas
weiße kuvertüre auf die kugel und
bestreut sie dann mit reichlich
kokosflocken
nach diesem schritt ist unser xxl
raffaello auch schon fertig und bereit
zum großen wiegen und jetzt wird mir
auch gerade klar warum ein raffaello
einfach nie reicht das sind nur zehn
gramm
und jetzt kommt unser xxl raffaello
mehr als drei kilogramm bringt es auf
die waage und somit vollkommen
ausreichend für mich das riesen
raffaello steht dem original in nichts
nach dem geschmacklich war das total
lecker und wir haben es wirklich sehr
genossen
falls ihr das ganze jetzt nach machen
möchte dann schaut doch mal in die
infobox da habe ich alle mengenangaben
für euch aufgeschrieben und ich freue
mich auch wenn ihr bei meinem nächsten
video wieder einschaltet